andere face tend to do a b c
noo
[music]
releasenote Apia's
favor mature with hp parano 4
voice and
tester me cdm
ec per me
ander 0 radar
3 d 6 a pas perdus
berberjin 3 nome ring
rapper
shoei s fun
Ngu re Arles terang to do
voodoo doom
Sequel Worker Japan
he to do
I'm worried if I can do
this today.  Yo
Polypro means that the
people who can speak the language of Fukusho are the
roads, right? Well, in English, Ringstar also says, but in
general, in other words, Polyblack in other things.  You see, it's from Glee Fire Department
. I know a lot, I think I can speak a lot of words. It
seems that I can have that meeting now.
About 500 in will start.
It's not that the number of people who can talk about luxury is decreasing, but people who are already interested in words.
Everyone
is soft to
each other and supports and supports each other. It's a very pleasant key
, so a similar meeting.  This time in Fukuoka, Japan, it's
from October 18th
to Skarn. I
swear it's the 20th when I was able to catch Japanese. It's 18 Kearney 11.
That's the first time in Asia, so Japan.  I think that people who are interested in studying the language and some
forms of Korea or China can be seen from other countries. Oh,
there are lots of interesting
meetings or speeches.  That's why, rather than quietly, those words
didn't make the sound of studying at
home. Let's go more than that. 2 sa It's a
new and new
phenomenon.
It's over when it becomes very easy to do,
and even when studying photoba.
Well,
at Sano Canada's English Farming School.  Only
Zuko Only English at French Agricultural School
Japan is already from a pattern that says one word with an English waterfall
[Music]
Anyone can do a lot of things in the land with five more.
It's easier to do, isn't it? The internet is very well net
fixed days or more. There are a lot of that
ideal, one string, or a lot of waterfalls,
so now to understand it correctly, by all
means.  Please come to another meeting, then I'm
looking forward to the exposure.